-Our first guest tonight
is a talented actor
who you know from his work
as Peter Parker
from both
the "Spider-Man" movies
and the "Avengers" franchise.
His latest film, "Uncharted,"
is in theaters and IMAX now.
Let's take a look.
-Do you think
it's another puzzle?
-Well, whatever it is,
you better figure it out fast.
I'm gonna try
and buy us some time.
Hey, can I get you a drink?
-Gin and tonic, por favor.
-This definitely isn't a gin and
tonic, but it is on the house.
-Gracias.
-Hey, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Let me guess, piña colada?
[ Crowd gasps ]
-[ Grunting ]
-The eye.
-Think you're a comedian there,
sunshine.
-Okay, I got it, I got it.
Sex on the Beach.
-Please welcome back to the show
our friend Tom Holland,
everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back, my friend.
-Hello, mate.
It's good to be back.
-It's great to have you here.
Last time you were here --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh.
-This is very appropriate
because, you know,
last time you were here,
you were promoting
the new "Spider-Man" film.
-Yes, I was, yeah.
-And it's done quite well
for itself.
-Yeah, the studio were happy.
-Yeah.
It's interesting,
with your show,
I feel like you can do a, like,
through the ages
of me growing up.
I came here, I don't know,
I was maybe 19.
I'm 25 now.
-Yep.
-It's always great
to be back here, mate.
So thanks for having me back.
-And every time you come,
I say to you --
I'm like, "I don't think
it's going to work.
I don't think show biz
is going to work for you."
And you keep ignoring me,
and I'm so happy.
-Yeah, constantly
[bleep] myself.
-But a tremendous -- I mean,
a movie that is so deserved.
And one thing, of course,
every time you're here,
especially if it's for anything
Marvel, one of the problems is,
you have to promote a film that
you can say very little about.
-Very true, very true, yeah.
I am a very honest person
just by nature.
-Yeah.
-Which has got me into trouble
in the past.
-Yeah. It seems like
you're even nervous now
you're going to spoil a movie
that everyone has seen.
-That is already out there.
-Yeah.
-But every time I say, like,
"So Tobey --"
I'm like, "Shh, shut up,
don't say that."
But yeah, I'm just very honest.
So on the press tour, you know,
journalists are like,
"So were Tobey and Andrew
in this movie?"
I'm like, "No, they're not.
Stop asking me that."
And I go home
and I almost can't sleep
because I feel so bad
for lying all the time.
-Yeah.
-I'm, like, calling up my mom.
I'm like, "I just feel so guilty
for all the lies."
[ Laughter ]
-Have you -- You should just go,
you should call
all those journalists
and be like, "I'm so sorry."
-I know, yeah.
-"I feel terrible about it.
I hope you understand."
-Yeah, I don't feel that sorry,
though.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
What was -- I mean, that is the
spoiler that could not be said
that we can now
let the world know.
But what was it like to work
with Andrew and Tobey,
the previous Spider-Men?
-Honestly, mate, it was
the most incredible experience
of my career.
To share the screen with them --
You know, playing Spider-Man,
while being
a wonderful experience
and, like, completely
life-changing,
it also can be quite alienating.
You know, when you're 19
and someone gives you
this opportunity
and your life changes,
it's quite hard to figure out
how to navigate.
So to almost have
like two older brothers
that had been through it
before me,
to be able to share
that experience with them
was amazing.
And I remember we were
shooting this scene,
which was really emotional --
like, a really,
really emotional scene,
and I was struggling to find the
emotion just because, you know,
when you make these big movies,
it can take two days
to shoot a scene.
I'd been crying for days on end.
So I went up to Andrew
and Tobey --
I nearly said Spider-Man
and Spider-Man.
[ Laughter ]
And I basically just said,
"Thank you,
thank you for being here.
Thank you for taking the time
to be a part of this, you know,
incredible opportunity.
It means the world to me."
And we all embraced,
and we all started crying.
And I remember the writers
sort of seeing that,
being like, "Yep, that's how
we're going to end the film.
[ Laughter ]
That's brilliant.
Well done, Tom."
And then the end of the film
is us having this moment
where I'm like,
"Thank you so much.
I really appreciate it."
And then we have this
beautiful hug, so it was's nice.
-That's really great
that you can both talk about
the experience
of playing Spider-Man,
which is obviously unique
to you guys,
and also wearing
the Spider-Man suit.
Because not a lot of people,
you know, do it at that level.
It's just, like,
the three of you
and that guy in Times Square.
-I'll give you a spoiler.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-You don't want to hug him.
Do not hug him.
-I'll give you a spoiler,
and I'm not going to
tell you who,
but one of us has a fake ass
in their suit.
-Really?
[ Laughter ]
Wow.
-You can figure out that
for yourselves.
-Well.
I mean, see, this is a real --
This is, you know --
Everybody thinks you're
such a nice guy,
but you're all about
ticket sales.
Because now everybody
is going back out
to try to find the fake ass.
-I remember being on set
and being like,
"Wow!
Oh, hang on a minute.
No, that's not real."
-Right?
At the wrap party, you're like,
"Where'd his ass go?"
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-This is -- This is very fun,
to do a film like this.
And I want to mention the clip
real quick.
You actually looked like
you had some bartending skills.
And I asked about it,
and you actually did
take this seriously.
You did a little bit
of bartending classes.
-Yeah, it was
an interesting one.
Nathan Drake as a character
is someone
who is incredibly capable
but in no way, shape,
or form trained.
So I wanted to find something
where I could convince
the audiences of his skill,
and I'd seen on YouTube
this flair bartending,
and I thought it was always
really cool.
So I thought that would be
a great way
to demonstrate to the audiences
that he's quite handy.
So I started taking
bartending classes,
and I actually went
to my favorite bar in London
and managed to convince
the bartenders
to let me go behind the bar.
So I ended up working these
kind of undercover shifts.
I had, like, the white tuxedo on
and everything.
-Yeah.
-But then the management team
found out, and I haven't
been allowed back since.
-In what -- in what --
I was going to say when
you had to convince them,
like, in what world do people
say, "No, Tom Holland.
You don't have your
bartender's license."
-I think the big part of it
was that, like,
they're charging a lot of money
and my drinks taste like [bleep]
-Oh, I see.
-And the patrons weren't happy.
-Yeah, like on Yelp,
they were like,
"While the espresso martini
was made by Tom Holland,
it tasted like [bleep]"
Three stars.
-Yeah, exactly.
-I have more questions
about "Uncharted."
We'll be right back with more
from Tom Holland.